our following guest was primarily a
backup at Oklahoma State yeah I had one
decent season starting and he rewrote
the record books that year but he was
mostly a backup at Oklahoma State you
might remember him for some of his huge
wildcard weekends with the Detroit Lions
and if you're like me you probably
thought he was tackled many times only
to watch him squirm out of a pile and
run 80 yards for touchdown
please welcome Hall of Fame running back
very cinder he doesn't look that
intimidating a lot of people said that
about you though right you always said
you could easily remember when we played
basketball one time in Denver and he's
Duncan now you're 5/8 he's standing on
the bed under the basket Duncan and I
said you could have played basketball in
college he goes I know and I think at
times at times growing up I mean I
showed probably more promise in
basketball I played varsity high school
basketball before I played varsity
football so it was just kind of I just
grew up playing it and loved it and
loved um you know Duncan on guys like
yourself no I know when did you know
though you had something special I don't
know I mean for me I don't know if that
thought ever came into my mind unless
someone said it to me and your dad
wasn't gonna say it to you no no I mean
he was pretty thing was to motivate my
dad's thing what's the motivate you know
so I think when I was Oklahoma State and
I saw I saw probably you know my
freshman sophomore year I saw guys going
off being drafted good players great
players that kind of thing guys I played
with and against that's probably when I
thought maybe I had a shot is the story
true that Barry Switzer said whatever
you do do not hurt
Thomas because if you do Barry Sanders
is coming in the game I've heard that
story repeated I don't know how much
truth there is to it honestly Thurmond
was such a great player and there were
so many great battles you know and I
don't I don't think because that would
have been my sophomore year I was like
just the returned guy which had a great
year returned the football and I don't
think anyone would would have predicted
or known what kind of player I would be
what is that feeling like though when
you're back there taking in a kick and
you see the whole field and you get to
improvise and do what you want and you
have the ability to be able to go and
score touchdown oh yeah no I loved it I
loved it for me just being in that
setting like I mean and I think you
alluded to it you know I wasn't heavily
recruited no one would have predicted
that I would be playing a major role or
have a lot of playing time and so just
being on the field in cotton as a
college football player especially as a
freshman sophomore I mean that was a
dream come true for me and so and the
fact that I was because my freshman year
I was more maybe on the kick kickoff
team or return team but I was I was one
of the blockers right so the fact that I
was you know in the back catching the
ball
you know the return guy that was a big
deal for me so so I loved it but I never
could have predicted you know what would
happen what kind of return guy would
have been but but no I to answer your
question no I I loved it kind of running
back would you be today today's game
look you meet not at your age the young
like 25
youngberry um I think I think in the
right situation you put me
you put me maybe in a you know Kyle
Shanahan offense you know then maybe I
can do some damage no you know a run
centered offense I mean ah I love all
the the offenses and schemes and things
like that that you see the Wildcats and
pistols and things like that
double tights and double fullback tape
run offense is just the creativity that
you know they didn't exist when I play
give me the answer your question I think
I do okay
give me the team you'd want to play for
well since they're in the Super Ball so
I'll see the Niners so what's that
because their offensive line and because
because they're in a Super Bowl I
understood well or if not the Niners
than the Chiefs but let's take those two
I'm honestly going to answer your
question since since in Detroit's
division we have Minnesota I love their
running this game they they they run the
ball obviously you know that so teams
like that I think with more soup meat
as I said the Niners maybe even Cowboys
I mean run run oriented teams I think
that'd be fun to play with you were a
Raider fan growing up were you
absolutely absolutely yeah I mean John
Madden
you know Otis Sistrunk Gene Upshaw Kenny
Stabler all those guys see I thought
what I thought that maybe you would have
come back to play for the Raiders when
you retired I think you were 31 and I
thought I wonder if you would come back
and play for the Raiders
did they was there any possibility of
you coming back and if you did would you
have played for the Raiders I don't
think there was ever any real
possibility I don't necessarily remember
who was there at that time at the
Raiders but yes I grew up an avid
Raiders fan but when I was when I
retired I think I was pretty much done I
realize knew it was over
you know and so it's catching on now
John Madden still been coaching and he
give me the call but you retired and you
were healthy all right yes
yeah these guys now that are retiring
like Andrew Luck had retires I mean
you've got guys who are walking away
from the game at the same age that you
did but it always felt like and I think
you expressed this you just you know you
fell out of love with it you didn't have
that passion you guys we're good
it felt like you had gone as far as you
were gonna go with the lines how much
did that will play into you just saying
all right at age 31 I'm gonna walk
away from this game I think most of it
was that just that I had lost enough of
that love and passion to continue to
play obviously it's hard to it's hard to
think about what would have been had I
been coming off of you know a deep
playoff run or Super Bowl run or
something like that I mean winning
obviously that changes everything but at
that time it was really just more about
where I was in my life and I think also
the fact that you know I had been so
fortunate man to play the game for ten
years the way that I did and so many
just fantastic memories I think that
kind of allowed me and almost gave me a
certain permission to be able to make
that decision but it was it was a
grueling tough decision oh we're talking
to Barry Sanders I remember I tell these
guys the Dennett's when I went to your
house you remember you called me up and
told me you were gonna buy a new car and
you wanted it and I you told me you were
gonna buy four-door uh-uh Honda Accord I
think and you want to know what I
thought if that was too flashy I called
you up and asked okay that sounds kind
of familiar because I did buy a it was
an Acura Legend okay because Acura
Legend is what I ended up purchasing
that would have been you know you're
talking 89 or something like that yeah
yeah because your car broke down on the
way to remember your car broke down when
you were gonna announce that you were
going pro right right this sure did it
broke down on the highway to your house
and you had a couch and a TV I think
that was it the house in Detroit and
then you had all day yeah at that point
no I mean I didn't have much my home
looked pretty much like a college dorm
you probably had Oklahoma State than you
did that first year absolutely I think
you even said you like what I've done
with the place and all you had was a
couch and a TV and I go yeah it looks
that you don't had no you had no artwork
he had no picture you had nothing I mean
you've heard of like the minimalist
philosophy was very very minimalistic
who's your favorite NFL player now
oh wow well I mean I love you take
Patrick mahomes you know you see what
he's done you see how dynamic of a
player he is and so I love seeing his
success he's had I love watching them
Brady still being able to play at a high
level at his age and and of course look
at what Gary Kennedy they did this year
awesome you know see the way he's come
on and played Chris McCaffrey who who
played at Stanford with my son and I
just had a dynamic year this year so
there's a you know a lot of great
players they all tend to be offensive
players ones that I like being friends
with defensive players on other teams
was that friends I don't know that
strangers that's a strong word okay
strong word say that no I shouldn't say
that I mean yeah you know who I would
consider a friend when I play I spend a
lot of time with off the field was
probably Reggie White it's Midtown where
Reggie you know going to his house his
home in Tennessee doing different events
with them so we would say we were
friends
I was cordial with most other beacons of
guys my try to stay away from him oh you
did a good job of staying away from him
Barry I've seen the highlights I've seen
the highlight that was the point that's
a little did you ever get hit really
hard like is there one that you remember
I think so yeah I think I think I mean
you never know the defensive players all
names though in the NFL I mean yes you
get hit apart all the time whether it's
in practice or a game or whatever but
not and I didn't try to Isildur a member
of someone's name and that kind of a
thing but but now you get you get
blasted often and you know so but no i
don't i can't think of one where it just
like knocked me out of the game no i
don't remember you ever getting hit like
that well I think I got hit plenty
plenty but not one of those where you go
oh wow because it always felt like if
nobody got a clean shot at you yeah
that's for the most part for the most
part I mean I I think I won most of
those battles but I think there's some
where you know yeah you know I probably
felt a little something you know it's
not something you want to it's not
somebody necessarily want to relive all
the time but but you know fortunately
yes I was able to escape most of that I
mean that was you know I would have to
say I mean and you only missed five
games due to injury thing six games
total in your career right that's pretty
good at that that's the way I ran I mean
I I loved I loved that part of you know
the strategy but making guys miss those
are the guys I I looked up to as a
runner growing up and I'm glad I was
able to do a good imitation of some of
my favorite runners also tell this story
just to make sure it's true you were
gonna win the rushing title could have
gone back into the game Christian Okoye
won the rushing title that year you were
asked if you wanted to go back in and
you said let your backup go in and get
some touches not true that's true to a
story when in the Russian title that was
our last game of the season my rookie
year as you pointed out we were in
Atlanta it had been a really good season
for me that game in particular was a
great game I knew that I mean I don't
know how many touchdowns I had but it
was you know couple touchdowns over 100
yards the game was well in hand it had
already like I said I mean it had been a
fantastic year I had will go on to later
win Rookie of the Year and so for me to
go back in and gain 10 or 15 yards to be
the NFL Russian leader for that season
it just didn't mean that much to me at
that time
so I'm I'm glad I made that choice but
like I said the game was over and I've
never been that kind of a stack guy and
so that's kind of just how I approach
the game why does it bother me more than
bothers you you ended up with 99
touchdowns no I know
good ol like I could have ended up with
99 and there's a couple of them that got
called back you know that for holding or
whatever you know I thought maybe they
were bad calls or whatever but but no I
know I know I would think that at least
been able to get to 100 well okay it
drives me crazy when your coach Wayne
fonts would take you out at the goal
line and I go why are you taking Barry
Sanders out of the goal line even if
you're not getting the ball I want you
there as the possibility of you getting
the ball well I would have loved to have
been in but that was a decision that
offensive coordinators made or Wayne
made you know it worked out it worked
out no it didn't you're joining us on
behalf of rocket mortgage and their
Super Bowl squares sweep saying this is
a big deal here oh it's a great deal
there's a lot of money here there is
absolutely as you said Rock the mortgage
Super Bowl squares sweepstakes just
giving fans a chance to win a lot of
money watching the game
$50,000 they have a chance to win for
every score change and at the end of
halftime at halftime at the end of the
game two fans have a chance to win half
a million dollars unbelievable
so you sign up for free at rocket movie
scores calm you know and you know how it
is I mean Super Bowl only two teams are
there most of us are our favorite teams
of not in it so gives you a chance to
really be invested in the game other
than just the fact you just the biggest
game in the world you know so good luck
to all the fans out there like a minute
mentioned before I mean it's free to
sign up so you have no reason to not
sign up possibly win a lot of cash and
and so we're just just really trying to
do something for the fans and you could
buy inaccurate or something like that so
rocket mortgage squares calm the
sweepstakes will close tomorrow at 11:59
p.m. Eastern did you know that I did I
got the whole pitch here I don't get in
trouble by anybody
rocket mortgage squares calm decent
running back
basketball player and and thanks man
thanks for making me a star too man I
know because you came to Wichita on
draft day 1989 Georgio's restaurant yeah
and interview me do you realize you got
drafted and then you disappeared and I
was there to just interview you and you
disappeared on me you mean that
particular day I got in trouble they're
like where's Barry I go I don't know
yeah with all my brothers and sisters
and family and friends view your other
brother was of course my bad no question
about it no he loved it he was sick for
him he was absolutely a little very
great to see you thank you buddy
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]